à athènes les files d'attentes ne sont
plus tout à fait là on les trouvait
habituellement auparavant situé au
niveau des innombrables monument qui
jalonnent la ville est composé de
nombreux touristes
elle se concentre aujourd'hui devant les
centres de test pour le coc vide 19 la
capitale hellénique se prépare à un
nouveau confinement général 194 jours
après avoir mis fin au premier
une mesure difficile mais obligatoire
pour le premier ministre grec kyriakos
mitsotakis a professé nous avons décidé
que dès samedi matin à six heures et que
nous mettrons en place un confinement
complet pour l'ensemble du pays qui
durera trois semaines jusqu'au 30
novembre
je choisis donc une fois de plus de
prendre des mesures drastiques le plus
tôt possible
de nombreux pays européens ont déjà été
contraint de prendre de telles mesures
mais ils les ont prises alors que
l'épidémie était déjà hors de contrôle
je ne peux pas prendre la responsabilité
de mettre la vie de nos concitoyens en
danger seuls les commerces essentiels
ainsi que les pharmacies resteront
ouverts par ailleurs pour sortir de chez
soi
les grecs devront indiquer le motif et
l'horaire par sms et obtenir un feu vert
des autorités
également par sms des annonces qui ne
surprennent pas beaucoup la population
dans ce pays pourtant relativement
épargnée par l'épidémie
des habitants qui reste néanmoins
inquiet des conséquences économiques de
ce nouveau confinement
avec tout ce qui se passait
était nécessaire pour que nous puissions
tous être protégé c'est un mois nous le
supporteront comme nous l'avons fait au
printemps
les choses sont difficiles nous essayons
de nous adapter à un ballet c'est très
difficile c'est très difficile pour tous
les entrepreneurs et les conséquences en
seront très bientôt visible il y a trop
de magasins qui ont fermé qui ne
rouvriront pas fait charme anadarko
mammadera en compliments qui concerne
également les différents camps de
migrants situé sur le territoire
ces derniers avaient dû déjà se re
confiné épisodiquement ces dernières
semaines en raison de nombreux cas de
kobe de 19